welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity it's the end of the world as we
know it at least that's what the left
and the mainstream media wants you to
think some compared Trump's meeting with
Putin to the Holocaust Pearl Harbor and
9/11 but the favorite new talking point
from some liberals never Trump hers and
their friends in the media is the
president Trump has committed treason
take a look I want to read the
definition of treason this is nothing
short of treasonous we're hearing a new
word right he said it was treason write
the words like you know treason and and
undermining you know our Republican
little case our rule of government are
being are being used now we have a
treasonous president the very fact that
reasonable people can disagree on
whether or not we're talking about
treason or high crimes and misdemeanors
or what-have-you I find genuinely
shocking and and seriously nauseating
joining us now with legal analysis of
these absurd claims is the author of the
book the case against impeaching Trump
Harvard Law Professor Alan Dershowitz
Dershowitz Fox News contributor Sarah
Carter Judicial Watch president tom
Fitton
all right but the professor Dershowitz
I'll go to you first
what is treason treason is the only
crime defined specifically in the
Constitution it shall consist only in
levying war against the United States or
an adhering to their enemies giving them
aid and comfort obviously it's wartime
it's what Aaron Burr was accused of
doing it's what people who became Nazis
and supported the Nazis and joined the
Nazi regime were accused of doing it's
not what President Trump did nor is it
what President Franklin Delano Roosevelt
did when he went to Yalta and sat down
with Stalin and allowed him to control
all of Eastern Europe many Americans on
the right will calling that treasonous
of treason but you can't just throw that
term around it's the only crime
specifically defined in the Constitution
I want to make one more point to compare
what President Trump did to the
Holocaust or to a crystal mock is a form
of Holocaust denial because what it
suggests is that nothing more happened
to the Jews that is happening today
Amerika it suggests there were no gas
chambers there were no killing fields
there was no plan to kill six million
Jews it's a disgraceful comparison well
and it just means the suffering that so
many people went through professor
without a doubt the pain of the
Holocaust is is is still rippling
through our society in the world as well
it should but Sarah Carter I'll go to
you
they also likened it to 9/11 3,000
Americans were attacked on 9/11 and
killed what do these Democrats and the
mainstream media do they really do they
like laugh in a corner or do they
believe this
you know I what's so frightening Jeanine
is that I actually think they believe
this and at first it would seem
laughable I was thinking the first time
I heard that I thought oh is this a joke
is this the crazy uncle in the corner
and then I kept hearing it over and over
and over again I mean CNN dedicated
nearly eight hours to calling the
president treasonous it is punishable by
death
think about that this is disinformation
this is a campaign against an
administration that is so volatile and
so dangerous look if they're worried
about Russia they should be worried
about themselves more because the
disinformation campaign that is coming
across on the media and from the Rhinos
and from the Democrats is far more
dangerous than what happened with Russia
well clearly I mean it is a hate
campaign tom Fitton and you know a year
ago you would ask for freedom of
information on certain documents
Department of Justice comes back and
says no no no no so in February of this
year you actually file a lawsuit I mean
you know you followed through with this
and now you're getting information I
believe on the minimally corroborated
dossier that we know was a fake and I
believe that we're now finding out that
that dossier was an essential part of
the FBI its application for the warrant
well this is a big deal in the sense the
FBI supposedly is going to give us I
would presume redacted materials about
the FISA application which this DNC
Clinton dossier was used to support so
we're going to get these FISA
application warrants or at least
versions of them that have been denied
to the American people thus far and it's
been a year
the cover-ups beginning to end and we'll
see just how far the deep states willing
to go in terms of showing exactly the
abuses that engaged in to target Trump
remember the allegation by Devin Noonan
is his intelligence community was that
but for there would be no FISA warrants
there'd be no spying on the Trump team
but for Hillary Clinton's dossier that
was wandered into the DOJ and FBI
through boosts or through the State
Department Sidney Blumenthal you name it
so this is this could be a big deal we
don't know we were supposed to get the
documents say we haven't even gotten
them yet right I saw that you were
supposed to get it today but everything
that you've been doing tom Fitton has
been a big deal by getting information
that Congress can't get but I'm gonna go
to you professor Dershowitz now let's
assume that tom Fitton
ends up getting information that that
proves that the dossier was totally an
essential part of the warrants and that
we know that hillary clinton paid for it
where do we go from there legally what
happens well there's a case called
Franks versus Maryland which says that
if a warrant it didn't deal with a
national security warrant it's even
worse if it's a national security
warrant because that's done ex parte and
the court is supposed to be able to
trust the people who are bringing it to
them but if it's based on misinformation
or failure to provide essential
information the entire warrant can be
thrown out and then you get to the issue
of fruit of the poisonous tree and it's
just not clear what it would do to the
ongoing investigation now in my book the
case against impeaching Trump I follow
through this whole analysis of what
would happen if in the event we had a
situation like that and we have to get
back to the point of treason as well you
know treason is an impeachable offense
that yes it's under cheb omit treason
and the only people who are subject to
impeachment are people who actually join
forces militarily
with our enemies and help them during
time of war people like Ezra Pound
people like a woman who broadcasts to
Americans people who Benedict Arnold
but treason is not something that can be
used against the president I just don't
do an American Sarah Carter what are
your what are your sources telling you
about the information that may be
released to tom Fitton well once this
information comes out I have been told
by numerous sources that the answers
will be revealed and it's going to be
explosive and this is the reason why
judge Jeanine the House Intelligence
Committee and the other committees want
the release of those documents they
don't want to allow the DOJ to continue
hiding this from the American public and
and tom Fitton just a few seconds you
know Congress wants it they don't want
DOJ to hide it as Sarah Carter just said
but you're the only guy getting it so my
hats off to you but I'm not wearing you
know you got it you got to go to court
Congress doesn't go to court come on
Congress join us right Professor Alan
Dershowitz Sarah Carter Tom Benton
thanks so much for being with us